okay let's do this now what's going on
here I drug trouble this is dead they
were here for you here for you who is
here and bikers after you killed Johnny
K and they damaged my stuff I they smash
up my home damaged my soul this this
this this this this statue here of
impotent rage this [ __ ] meant more to
me than Johnny came in to anyone and
they smashed it this pathetic midlife
crisis hog ridin shaven-headed fruity
leather chap learn [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] Trevor they are there I
can wear in [ __ ] hey wait wait you
little [ __ ] whoa whoa hey Michael
[ __ ] Townley right [ __ ] wife two
kids 45 find them those Saints otsuka
big big place Trevor across to people
you are [ __ ] useless hmm find out who
did that [ __ ] robbery all right and
if Michael Townley lived there or anyone
matching his description I'm gonna kill
you and your [ __ ] cousin am I being
clear now yes Trevor thank you wait now
smile yeah that's better run along
that's that bat now Ron shall we go
cannot believe that they [ __ ]
destroyed my statue of impotent rage the
cheek the [ __ ] chica
make a stop at ammunation you're meeting
me at the lost MCS airfield let's do the
stretches I love it I'll come in your
ear when I get a hold you oh I'm not
buying anything i need a sniper rifle
the high-powered scope they say they
support local business well we're about
to find out of that true melvin how you
feel about brand synergy huh TP industry
ammunation that sniper on your wall
looks like it'll do the job hmm that's
the chestnut you got a scope and a
suppressor for this it'll be quiet as a
mouse get that look off your face I know
you sold Cletus has gotten he ain't got
three brain cells I'm a 10
let's get some a fine shirt no I guess I
my waking hours surrounded by gun have
fun close the door behind you it's all
right on Ron Ron I got the gun Mimi it's
a water tower just north of the airfield
[Music]
course there are two planes are touching
down in the field on a weapons run we're
gonna wait till the right time and afro
creator oh wow
I make sure that my armors on we are
[Music]
okay I don't see the hardware but I do
see a hell of a lot of bikers come up a
line we gotta wait till you can slip in
there unnoticed should give you the time
to plan a roof of the gas tank your
rigging up the blow really
perfect just when I need some daylight
now [ __ ] dark in the time is right go
on my son whenever you get it down your
mind I want you to remember that I'm
watching you to the scope of a
high-powered rifle right right right got
it now relax the ATV can only take you
so far Park it and don't let them spy
you believe this rod one of these
[ __ ] is having a seizure or
something shoot well get move on I
gotcha Covered come on come on
[Music]
there's one and there's the other now
don't shoot the guy in the band so he
sobs gets out
alright
fire we gotta see myself to I think is
just call the tank I you know listen now
you should see those on his face great I
take him out of the control tower cam
quick he's gotta go where is it
[Music]
come on take them
where the [ __ ] is it with a [ __ ] thing
hi there so long sailor there we go
Johnny go Scott got stuck on me trip
scared you're in my crosshairs again
there's no one left to kill so get over
to that gas tank and plant the bomb I
can't
others always hated that chopper get
[ __ ] drive your biker times when I
got if I hit the chopper everyone's
gonna know we're here
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
one dead biker it is good to me is
another I hope there's enough of these
guns go around
yeah but
look at
[Music]
and I'll start that plane I'm afraid I
gotta confiscate this weapon dream
I brother I brought it I brought it
great Trevor just like you can press to
the guns must be on the playing down the
end of the runway
Oh
but yeah me too my playing on
what the fuh happen
should be on the link
come on oh
[Music]
let's see what
Toronto
happy to my spine rod
yet
oh god dad
it's 13 you further cuts wet
let's do this [ __ ] I don't fly a
plane but I learned today
because is in a folk just off the coast
justified you are you injured I am aware
of them well the man on my wing for this
no immediate danger I'll do my best to
oblige you there's only two places this
kind of hardware is gonna go back at
down up north to our Canadian cousins
where the lots were likely to be sending
them around your neighbor those in the
south are next in breven just get up
canada why was you making it something
like that why is it obvious now let out
for me before i order you to fly that
plane into a mouth yeah yeah I was
it's Indiana
this is how so very beautiful
that beautiful glad I don't have a shirt
on right now
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh that's him let's do it
what do we know it
it could show up on military radar
ah
shipment successfully delivered wrong
now remember you beat me to the airstrip
all butcher your carcass and wrapped in
cheesecloth perfect beat me and you'll
see successfully delivered wrong now
remember if you beat me to the airstrip
all butcher your carcass and a rap Yaya
hella better at it or fly through born
laughter I love
[Music]
yes boss
Mexico yes 9 the boat is off you're
gonna just to hide our tell like I
hadn't thought of that we might be able
to buy in the Oscar thing but leave that
to me rod oh he may remember any in this
story country will talk about the exact
flight when we're grounded America
okay why apply why are we there yet
flash per day
okay okay [ __ ] appalling but drawn
now remember if you feed me to the
airstrip off butcher your carcass and
Mexico yeah kinda boat is Oscar gunman
he's in with the cartel like I hadn't
thought of that we might be able to bind
the Oscars thing but leave that to me
rob a better than any in this story
country will talk about the exact plate
when we're grounded okay all right
nice and slow
nice and slow
playback
ok
ok
yeah I think that was adequate
restitution for my impotent rage statue
that was a mighty fine statute rest I
was a mighty fine piece of plastic [ __ ]
but there is no price for emotional
attachment I mean you might forego your
cut to alleviate my heartache I might
yeah I mean I will good idea we don't
have time to dwell on that now because
we got more runs Ron if there is one
thing that they need south of that big
fence it is gone Trevor Phillips
industries technical expertise yes
managerial innovations unstoppable oh
that's right now go I need to manatee
Loremaster our boat back out again
[Music]
ok
okay okay anyways thanks for watching
guys back yeah